Here's an example of a product I think provides a clear
system image. What if you were in a meeting room or
cafeteria, where someone was having a heart attack? The room had
a heart defibrillator on the wall, which you're seeing here. But
let's say you had never seen or used one before. What
would you do? Those who designed the device aren't present, no
medical personnel or trained responders are around, and anxious helpers don't
have time to read a manual, not even a simple one.
Here's a product where designers have to communicate
the proper model of operation quickly. So what
you're seeing here is the solution the design
firm IDEO came up with for defibrillators. The device
walks users through three steps, each clearly marked
and numbered. The screen, visible here, with the
number two, gives specific instructions as users are
interacting with the device. And as you can see
from this diagram, two electrodes needs to be placed on the patient and
the diagram clearly communicates where they need
to be placed. It's pretty straight forward.